les réseaux sociaux match dyneema syrien
de 32 ans a tout d'un chercheur aguerri
un cv qui affiche trois différentes
universités en turquie une quatrième en
hongrie trois langues étrangères
maîtriser la participation à plusieurs
conférences sur le conflit syrien et
même une collaboration avec un centre
d'études à istanbul
toutes ces informations sont disponibles
grâce à ses comptes sur les réseaux
sociaux
et pourtant derrière ce brillant profil
mach dîner manette autre qu'un ancien
combattant ait porte-parole du groupe
terroriste djeich à l'islam
l'organisation qui a compté jusqu'à plus
de vingt mille combattants a fait régner
la terreur dans les zones qu'elle
contrôle est principalement dans la
route à orientale perdu en avril 2018
et devinez où cet homme a été arrêté à
marseille le 29 janvier pour acte de
torture et complicité crimes de guerre
et complicité de disparitions forcées
match dit là mais était en possession
d'un visa erasmus dans le cadre d'un
échange universitaire avec l'université
d'aix marseille
il a d'ailleurs été très facile pour moi
de retracer son historique puisque tout
est à portée de main sur internet
l'ema aurait quitté donc la syrie en
2015 où il combattait aux côtés d'autres
terroristes
il aurait ensuite rejoint la turquie
pour ses études
et ça avait l'air plutôt de bien
fonctionné pour lui puisque sur son
compte twitter il était suivi par plus
de trente six mille abonnés il indique
être chercheur spécialiste de la syrie
et vice-président d'un think tank turc
sur linkedin son parcours est un peu
plus détaillé il se revendique comme
étant spécialiste des questions de
sécurité et de terrorisme en syrie il
est même recommandé par des confrères de
travail
l'ex combattant passé si bien qu'il
avait même été interviewé l'année
dernière par le new york times qu'il
avait appelé l'exilé et son appartenance
et indiquer de manière assez explicite
toujours en fouillant un peu dans son
parcours on tombe sur une lettre de
recommandation demandé par match
emma pour intégrer le programme erasmus
je suis chercheur spécialiste de la
syrie et plus particulièrement
concernant la sécurité le terrorisme
j'ai été impliqué dans la révolution
syrienne
j'ai joué un rôle majeur dans les
actions de la révolution j'ai besoin
d'une lettre de recommandation le plus
rapidement possible pour m'inscrire au
programme d'erasmus la semaine prochaine
un autre détail assez perturbant sur sa
page facebook l'ancien combattant suit
le conte d'un certain ziad majed qui a
pour photos profils les quatre disparus
qui auraient été torturés et tués par
janisch l islam
le groupe pour lequel match dyneema
combattez en syrie l'avocate et
journaliste syrienne razan zaitouneh son
mari waël hamada et d'autres ses
collaborateurs sami el khalil enez m
ahmadi ils n'ont jamais été retrouvés
alors on peut se poser une question
comment cet homme qui faisait partie
d'un groupe terroriste connu
mondialement a pu passer à travers les
mailles du filet jusqu'à atterrir chez
nous en france il ya d'eau moins sur le
site erasmus match dyneema avait même
publié une annonce dans laquelle il
chercher un logement à marseille afin de
poursuivre ses études dans la ville
selon la fédération internationale des
droits humains match dina mais plus
connu sous son nom de combattants islam
allauch aurait été à la tête du groupe
qui fut régulièrement accusées d'enrôler
des enfants plusieurs victimes le maître
également directement en cause pour des
faits d'enlèvement et de torture
le 26 juin 2019 la fidh avait déposé une
plainte contre le groupe terroriste qui
a permis l'ouverture de cette enquête